Dear Viola.
Dear Sandra.
Thank you, Jane.
...for inspiring me to stand up for myself
and make sure that I'm heard.
You never know what the impact
of your actions are gonna be,
and then you read a letter like this.
As an athlete, we are able to use
our platform to help people
see what's going on.
To quote Sandra Oh,
"It's an honor to be Asian!"
You can have profound ripple effects.
There is a core narrative about all of us.
She's too hard, she's too old,
she's too much of everything.
And in many instances, it's wrong.
There was a talent show, and I sang.
Instantly, the bullying stopped.
It was the beginning of
understanding my own power.
I thought, "If Malala can do
so much at a young age,
maybe I can too."
So many people around the world
are speaking out.
Dear Ava, I'd be willing to bet
that you didn't realize
the hundreds of children
you'd be saving from incarceration.
Wow... that makes me emotional.
Dear Laird.
I've been able to accomplish things
which many believed were impossible
with my condition.
I owe this enlightened mindset...
To you, Laird.
Andre, you saw the beauty in me
at a time where
I couldn't see it in myself.
The world is full of inspiration.
I have never been angry.
The best revenge is to promote education.
You continue to inspire
a generation of people.
Billy, if I hadn't heard your voice...
My life would look completely different.
I realized I am the change
I'm looking for.
I can't make my life longer,
but I can make it deeper.
Dear Billy.
Dear Malala.
Dear Laird.
Dear Jane.
Dear Viola.
Dear Sandra.
Dear Andre.
Dear Ava.
Dear Kareem.
What is your voice?
What are you gonna do with that
small dash of time that you have?
May we keep riding the big waves.
May we continue in the fight together.
Dear Malala.
Dear Jane.
Dear Billy.
Dear Sandra.
I'm gonna make the claim that
you have the best face in the world.
Sorry, that's hilarious.